c луганський рок гурт шевченка band рідна
мова музиканті вру сиська то збивають
іван і а буму і російську та українську
над двором до того он і виїхав з клуні
нам луганська і к і проросійські сили
чудово мазох стряхнути куму в еру
сиську йому ви легко вловити україни
музиканти vpn і не вся ситуація була
підготовлена ​​за зданий
з чим лідку 2012 року режим януковича про
хван їх закон про засідки мовляв на південь
равликів та
вінда кликав і ви просто висновок орхідних
регіонах до багата на російську розумних
російську парять державну українську
закон дійсно паскудний тут
заговорити правді
просто забираючи про ще говорить в Україні
мої будуть і модні води дорівнює українці
canon c та закон так закликали у у вогонь та
у кримському харчуванні мортон війська
чоловіки теж не дуже багато він був
дуже не вчасно прийнято якщо майдану
верховна рада засідки блискавки кулі такі
види януковича раз пробував as косово ти
йди на виступила вище пік і сови кінного
табу в позові президента Олександра
турчинова теж до липня закінчено і c
посмажити експерти зовсім на кістку
українське море
вартості така ситуація ще різанини і ну
національні машини може ну чи мені
потрібно за гольові кури 100 ват та його
у чат і державному та c безпосередньо милу
миру та дисбаланс кримінальної політики у
тримаючи вік такий у дворі списів сотні
народних депутатів домагається дуби
seaweed конституційному суду розряду їх
його покличу з чудового знання модних засідок
януковича неконституційним та ух
волинами з дорученням а регламенту раді
праворуч наріжте потягнути слуху то 17
листопада політолог олексій гарань не
виключаючи скошування закону судом алла
депутатам сліди роботи на багата більше
про з рожевого ви вирішите і можна проблему
в Україні за ноутбуком за фіксату
перший статус кво топ-20 те, що право
російському
громадян напрошуються ще у нас є
save мови
яких можна забути 5 тис і діловодство та
цін на терек російському ваала проціону
рубля царя чіпа запросто українську мову
і
шевченко band популяризував українську в
донбасі біля ставків
авто них 16 рокер вин бакунова фроггі
мені українську вже на пиво
купава нам луганську теж до самого
могутня хоча б 4
нікому вона частини США club sea spa
дівається з чудо бате у конституційному
суді нових краще за їх політичних за
держбуд у їхньому розумінні
різанини мови може spooky нас пиві знову
ти я кривизні стиль і музика